[MUSIC PLAYING]
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: So
it is a huge pleasure
to be able to announce
our chef here in a moment.
I'm going to take
about five minutes
and give a quick
background that's
not going to do Chef justice
on the amazing attributes
that he's had over
the past years.
I'm Scott Giambastiani.
I'm with the food team--
the Google food program.
And it's my pleasure
to announce Chef here.
A quick bio on his
background, and then we'll
get into the demonstration.
Questions, I believe, are
going to be kind of fielded
throughout the demo.
He would appreciate that
interaction from you guys.
And then after
the demonstration,
there will be some
sampling of two
of the dishes, which
I'll talk about.
And then right at 12:35,
since we started late,
Chef will go into
a book signing.
So I know everyone
has their books there.
And thank you for coming
on time, if not early.
So with that, James Syhabout,
our guest here today,
was born in northeast Thailand
before his family immigrated
to Oakland in 1981 amongst
a community of refugees
after the conclusion
of the Vietnam War,
growing up watching his mother
cook in Thai restaurants.
After graduating from the
California Culinary Academy--
a fellow alumni.
Thank you, Chef--
back in '99, James
left to hone his
craft abroad, working
in some of the most
reputable kitchens I'm
sure you've heard of, including
The Fat Duck in the UK,
then under Dan Patterson
at Coi in San Francisco,
as well as a season
at elBulli in Spain.
So some really
top-end restaurants.
Then in 2009, James opened his
first restaurant in Oakland,
called Commis, which
holds two Michelin stars.
He then opened Hawker
Fare in Oakland,
which is now closed,
and then reopened
in San Francisco in 2015.
He's also the co-owner of
Old Kan Beer and Company.
Anyone been there yet?
I have to check that out.
Beer garden-- super cool.
He's the founder of
Hawking Bird, both of which
are in Oakland.
His book today, which
everyone has, "Hawker Fare,"
was created to honor his
heritage and immigrant parents.
His parents were born from
two distinct Asian cultures.
His mother's ancestral
village is in Isan, Thailand,
and his father in Pakse, Laos.
His family arrived
in Oakland in '81,
again, as a community of
refugees after the war.
And the book is not only
a beautiful articulation
of the stories of his life,
his travels, and his family,
but also has amazing recipes.
But more so, the imagery in
there is just spectacular.
So I see a lot of you
flipping through it.
So please make sure to
find your favorite recipe
and have him sign that.
Each recipe in the
cookbook is detailed
by the story of its
inspiration and creation.
And then today, Chef will
demonstrate two recipes--
the duck laap and Da's
blistered green beans,
which I had at the
restaurant when I was there.
As I mentioned, if you want to
try the vegetarian options--
it sounds like that's a
no-- those are available.
I do want to thank Paul Rivera.
Raise your hand, Paul.
Paul's one of our Googlers
out of San Francisco who
had reached out to the
food team and said,
you need to get him back here.
When was your last talk?
You did one a while back.
JAMES SYHABOUT: I think
right before we opened
Hawker Fare in San Francisco.
I think 2015, yeah.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: All right.
So every three years, we need to
just bring him back here again.
So it's a huge pleasure to be
able to welcome Chef James.
So please give him
a round of applause
and let him do his thing.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMES SYHABOUT:
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you for whoever
traveled here.
I know the traffic.
Sometimes, five miles can be a
long five miles down the 101.
So how many of you have
read the book already?
Yeah?
So there may be
some reiterations--
so I apologize--
of, like, the story
of how the book came about.
But the format of this demo--
I want it to be like a
conversational piece.
So please interrupt me.
The questions don't have to
be directly about the dish
I'm cooking.
It could be general.
It could be about culture.
It could be about ingredients.
It could be about anything
in general, you know?
Talk about favorite hobbies.
So I'm going to demo two dishes.
The first one we do
is the Da green beans.
My mother's name
is [INAUDIBLE]----
Da for short.
And this dish is kind
of a tribute to her.
It's a traditional Thai dish.
Actually, we had this
recipe at the restaurant,
but it kind of morphed
to a home-cooked meal.
Usually it's called [THAI].
It's made with candied pork,
green beans, homemade chili
paste, oyster sauce, sugar.
That's very, very simple.
The question you might ask
is, how did we get to bacon?
So the story about
the bacon part,
which I'm going to
start and get going--
growing up in Oakland,
we were on welfare.
So food stamps is
how we survived
and how we fed ourselves.
And with food stamps,
you were limited
to what you can buy
at the grocery stores.
And that's when I was
introduced to Oscar Mayer bacon.
And instead of candied pork,
bacon was the substitute.
Is it on?
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Fans.
Thank you.
JAMES SYHABOUT: So
that's how bacon
was the substitute for that.
So just like a lot of
the recipes in the book,
it's not meant to be authentic.
It's kind of a filtration
of traditional dishes
that got adapted to our
living situation in Oakland
back from when we
were growing up.
These are just Blue
Lake green beans.
Just pick off the stem end.
And you're just going to
deep fry ahead of time.
And you can leave
this at room temp.
The oil's about 375 degrees.
It's a very, very quick fry,
just enough for the skin
to blister and crinkle
up, but still remains
a good crunch and texture.
Throw the rest of them in here.
It's a fairly
quick, easy recipe.
At the restaurants that we
served at, we didn't use bacon.
[LAUGHS] We used just
sliced pork that's
been cooked down
with sugar and water
until the water and the juice
of the pork's completely dry.
And then the sugar caramelizes
and caramelizes itself.
But at home, time was an issue.
So my mother didn't
know what bacon was.
And she knew it was a pork
product and it was pork belly.
And she grabbed a package
of Oscar Mayer bacon
and started making this at home.
And actually, the very first
time I actually had this dish
was with the bacon.
So I didn't know better.
I didn't know where
she was coming from.
I never had the
traditional way until we
opened our restaurants.
That's good enough.
I'm going to get all of it out.
So we'll just push
this to the back.
So the beans can sit chill
out for a little bit.
I like this.
This is cool.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: You
can ask me to do this.
I haven't done this
in months over here.
You keep talking.
We'll get this thing rolling.
JAMES SYHABOUT: OK.
Cool.
So I'm not sure if
this is Oscar Mayer.
But it doesn't have to be.
It's just a funny thing.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
Get that one on high.
Thank you.
JAMES SYHABOUT: When
we wrote the book,
I think I had,
like, 120 recipes.
And we only had
room for about 90.
So I had to do a lot of edits.
And to me, it's
like, which recipe
counts to include in the book?
Which recipe tells a story?
Which recipe sets
a tone and mood?
And also unique-- not to
be innovative in any way--
just more to make
the story cohesive
of what I wanted to write--
like a memoir of growing up.
So this is a direct
reflection of a dish,
of a sense of place
and time in my life.
The bacon gets rendered a
little bit with the fat.
Use a spoon.
Dirty dishes.
So if you were to
do this with bacon,
I would suggest buying
a slab, and cutting it
thicker in batons, like
we do at the restaurant.
You get more of a better bite.
And that's the
only change I made
to my mom's original recipe.
We'll let the fat
render it a little bit.
It doesn't have to
be super crispy.
The rest of our ingredients
are really, really simple.
We have oyster sauce.
It's a Thai brand.
Homemade curry paste--
making curry paste,
you can make a lot of it.
It lasts.
It's pretty much bomb-proof.
Between the shrimp paste,
all the dry ingredients,
the capsaicin, it's
a preservative.
If you have this in your
pantry, you can pretty much make
a lot of the recipes in
the book really easily,
like the [INAUDIBLE]
noodles, the [INAUDIBLE]
also have the same paste.
So this is very, very versatile.
So if you really have
to muscle your way
in to just making this for this
dish, just make a lot of it.
It just saves you
so much more time.
The bacon's there.
I don't want it
completely crisp.
A little caramelization's fine.
I just want to add
the curry paste.
Kind of fry the
curry paste to get it
fragrant into the bacon fat.
So I'll use the
back of the spoon
to try to make it evenly--
[INAUDIBLE] spice.
Turn on the heat a little bit.
And then we're going
to add the green beans.
Just turn off the heat.
And pretty much everything's
cooked at this point.
You can kind of go off the heat.
Oyster sauce, sugar.
AUDIENCE: Most of
the ingredients
you can find at
regular Asian markets?
JAMES SYHABOUT: Yeah.
You go to a Restaurant United,
you'll find everything.
Yeah.
Except for some of the
specialty Thai brand sauces.
You might have to try a
little bit more searching.
I think Chef [INAUDIBLE] took
a trip to Oakland to some Lao
marks and Thai markets to
find a couple of ingredients.
AUDIENCE: He was
searching a little bit.
JAMES SYHABOUT: Yeah,
a little hunting.
But you know, oyster sauce
brands are very important.
Some have higher salinity.
Some are sweeter.
Same thing with fish sauce--
in the book, there's a landscape
photo of all the bottled sauces
and stuff you would use.
So I did that just because,
sometimes, your mind spins
when you go to an
Asian market, you know?
You're staring at the soy
sauce shelf for, like, an hour.
I'm like, which
one am I getting?
So I made that picture,
so, pretty much, you
just walk to a store with that
photo and just know the labels.
This is makrut lime leaves
or kaffir lime leaves.
A little bit of chiffonade then.
We don't waste anything in our
household, even the little old
end bits, unlike Commis,
where we waste everything.
We like a perfect leaf.
Use 10% of it.
Throw away the rest.
Or it goes to staff meal.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Chef,
other than the bacon,
which is not, you say, typically
traditional for this dish,
this dish is pretty
common in general.
Are there other
aspects of this dish
that you do differently
from a traditional bean
dish like this?
JAMES SYHABOUT:
Actually, there's
a version of it with catfish--
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Catfish?
JAMES SYHABOUT:
--actually, yeah,
where you roast
the catfish whole,
pick the meat out, let it
little dry a little bit,
and you fry it.
And you just crumble it on top.
Yeah.
So there's a pescatarian
version of the dish as well.
And there's also a condiment
that you make with catfish
with the same
curry paste, sugar.
You take the catfish,
and it's caramelized,
and the same sauce.
And it's almost like a Thai
version of [INAUDIBLE]..
So you come home sometimes,
a warm pot of rice
has been cooking.
I just sprinkle that on
top, fry an egg on it,
and I have a meal.
AUDIENCE: What
does your mom think
of your rendition of the dish?
JAMES SYHABOUT: She
thought it was funny.
She thought it was interesting.
She didn't remember
much, obviously.
And she was like, I used bacon?
I'm like, yeah.
Yeah, Oscar Mayer.
We went to Safeway.
You don't remember?
The grocery outlet.
We got a package of
Oscar Mayer bacon.
Yeah, it's so funny.
She knocked my
curry paste, though.
She's like, it's
not spicy enough.
I'm like, you know, I want
it more fragrant than spicy.
I kind of threw it back at her.
Like, was grandma's curry
paste different from yours?
She's like, yeah.
I was like, exactly.
You know, everyone kind of
adopts their own flavor,
which brings me to talk about
the book and the recipes.
The recipes are
a baseline guide.
Feel free to adapt to your
spice level, sweetness level.
Don't search for authenticity,
because it is a unicorn.
It doesn't exist.
A unicorn, for me,
has three horns.
Perfect example--
I went to Thailand
for a month on the first
trip with John Birdsall,
my co-author, and [INAUDIBLE].
And we had som tam, or tam som--
papaya salad-- maybe
twice a day for 30 days.
And my argument, just
to prove it, was,
how can you argue Auntie's
papaya salad is more authentic
than the other person's?
You can't.
It's situational.
People come from
different backgrounds.
People have different
tastes and different palates
and different lives.
I did that not just to
argue the term authenticity.
I am the same type.
But what's authentic
is the nuances
and the foundation of the dish.
Papaya salad, depending
on where you're from,
always has, some
sort of fish sauce.
Either it's clarified
or it's [INAUDIBLE],,
depending on if you're from the
north, or you're from the south
or you're from central Thailand.
There's always papaya.
There's always tomatoes.
Central Thai people
like to not have
[INAUDIBLE],, because they're
used to something sweeter
and having peanuts and dried
shrimp, where in the north
we use [INAUDIBLE],,
fermented whole fish,
sometimes salted river crabs.
And it's not spicy and
there's no sugar in it at all.
So it's more and more savory.
So it's like, OK,
which one is authentic?
It's like, they're all authentic
in their own very unique way.
So when you make
these recipes, I
think it's easier
actually to make
the first one exactly dead-on
to the recipes and then eat it.
It's just like, what
do I like about it?
How can I make it to
my liking, if you don't
like a certain thing about it?
Kind of adjust as you go.
Making the recipes are
hard, because, when
I was writing the book and doing
recipes for the first time,
I'll do taste memories.
And that's how my fine dining
culinary skills came into play.
I can analyze flavors.
I know techniques.
But I got into trouble, where
I was kind of overthinking it.
My mom always tells me,
you're overthinking it.
Just throw it in.
And that's the beauty
about this food.
They're very, very instinctual.
I'm near my gram scale
taring everything,
measuring everything.
She's looking at me, shaking
her head, like you're just
wasting your time.
And she's right.
And the times that she made
this dish or other dishes
maybe 100 times, they
all taste different.
There's no measurements.
Sometimes, she
omits ingredients.
She replaces ingredients.
But the nuances are there.
And they're all
just as satisfying.
And I don't remember
the different versions,
but I just know that
nuance is there.
And that's what I
remember the most.
And that's kind of
where I cook from.
And the rest is kind
to my personal taste.
But she had this dish.
She was like, you put
too much bacon in it.
I'm like, I love bacon.
What's wrong with more bacon?
It's like, "mo'
bacon, mo' better."
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
You mentioned
this is a simple dish.
And I don't want to downplay
the fact that I just
counted the ingredients.
It's almost, like, 15 or
16 different ingredients.
And the reason I mention that
is, trying to make vegetables
delicious and craveable
is not always easy.
And I come from a background
of Italy and English,
as far as my parents go.
And my mom would cook beans--
typically just boiled beans.
And so to compare
that to this, which
is just screaming
with flavor and aroma,
you guys are in for a treat.
So really, really cool.
JAMES SYHABOUT: Cool.
Yeah, the hard part of this
dish is the curry paste.
If you have a shrimp allergy,
just omit the shrimp paste.
You'll be fine.
You won't miss it.
I substituted oyster
sauce for a Thai light soy
sauce or a seasoning sauce.
You won't get the viscosity.
You won't coat
the beans as good.
But it'll still have
the same umami flavor.
AUDIENCE: What is galangal?
JAMES SYHABOUT:
Galangal-- it's a rhizome.
It's almost like ginger.
You cannot use ginger
as a substitution.
A lot of people
make that mistake.
It's totally different.
It has sharp, almost
citrus notes to it.
It's more fibrous, so you've
got to really, really chop
it to digest it.
It's mostly used
to steep in things
like soups and
curries and whatnot.
It's edible, but you have
to slice it very thin
or pound it into
the chili paste.
AUDIENCE: If we're in
a bind and you just
want to buy a curry paste,
which one would you recommend?
JAMES SYHABOUT: Which
one do I recommend?
I recommend a brand
called Mae Anong.
M-A-E, second word, A-N-O-N-G.
It comes in a pouch,
not in a tub.
Yeah.
And they actually make
different curry pastes.
That's what my mom used
at the restaurants.
Because making the curry
paste is so labor intensive.
And it's not as cost effective.
Back then, my mom opened her
restaurant in '88 in Concord.
I mean, that with a
side of rice was $4.
So making your own
curry paste was not
in the books with three
people in the kitchen doing
200 covers with a lunch menu
that was, like, 26 items.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Wow.
JAMES SYHABOUT: Yeah.
It was a true mom
and pop restaurant.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: What's
that called again?
JAMES SYHABOUT: Mae Anong.
M-A-E, second word, A-N-O-N-G.
I might have spelled it wrong.
But if you go to
any Thai market,
you'll see different
curry pastes.
Some comes in the tub.
But this comes in a pouch.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES SYHABOUT: Let me see it.
JAMES SYHABOUT: That's it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JAMES SYHABOUT: Yep.
So she makes a basic red.
And also, she makes
a Peking version
that has pretty much more
kaffir lime leaves in it.
Yeah.
But I prefer just to get
the red as your base ground
and then add fresh
kaffir lime leaves in it.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] make your own.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Chef,
can we pass a little slice
of the galangal around
so people can see that?
JAMES SYHABOUT: Of course.
Yeah.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Thank you.
JAMES SYHABOUT: It's
different aromas.
Any questions on
the green bean dish?
I'm going to make
sure the recipe works.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Is this one
of your more popular sellers
at the restaurant?
JAMES SYHABOUT: Yeah.
We sell a lot of green beans.
I always joke with my GM.
It's like, we can just be,
like, a five-dish restaurant.
We'll be fine.
It's this, fried chicken,
[INAUDIBLE],, and [INAUDIBLE]----
barbecue chicken--
and sticky rice.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: I think I
ate all those when I was there.
JAMES SYHABOUT: The rest
is kind of like filler.
[LAUGHS] And [INAUDIBLE].
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Nice job.
JAMES SYHABOUT: Next dish,
we're going to make laap.
You might see, on Thai
menus, different spellings.
Some people call it larp with
a P. Some people spell it
with a B. I don't
know the correct way.
I think they're all correct.
Depending on where you're from,
your pronunciation of the dish
is different.
Laap is a genre of salads--
protein salads pretty much.
And when I say salad, it's not
meant to be like a Caesar salad
where you eat it by itself.
[LAUGHS] I think
people get it wrong.
When people say "salad,"
in Western culture,
we think it's a first
course, and that's
what we eat before
our next thing.
Lao and Thai food,
everything comes
to the table at the same
time, or as it comes,
and you eat everything
with each other.
There's counterparts to it.
It's a constructed meal
rather than sequential.
So growing up, laap was
also a very masculine thing.
When we had dinner
parties or birthday
parties in our backyard,
it's the men who
makes the laap, not the women.
I think it goes back
to the villages.
The men were herders and
took care of the livestock,
so they did all the butchery.
And it's nose-to-tail cooking.
Nothing gets wasted.
But I chose duck only because
I remember, as a child,
we used to get live ducks from
[INAUDIBLE] whenever my parents
would do the slaughter.
I remember plucking
feathers for them.
I remember holding the duck
while my father slit the duck's
neck and bled it and made
different variations of laap.
One was a raw one with blood
coagulated over the meat.
It was like a panna cotta.
It was called laap [INAUDIBLE],,
which didn't make it
to the book for many reasons.
One, because no one's
going to make it.
And also, I didn't want
the animal rights people
knocking on my door.
But that's going to be
the B-sides of the book.
However, I got a whole duck.
I'm going to butcher this guy.
I got some gloves.
You can use just duck
breast or duck legs
if you need to buy parts.
You don't have to buy a
whole duck to use the recipe.
I champion the legs
more than the breast.
The connective
tissue is delicious.
It's a darker, richer flavor.
It is something that more
resembles, say, a wild duck.
That's what I'm going for.
So I'm going to take this apart.
I'm just going to
make a small portion.
But today, I'm just
going to mix the two.
That is the breast.
And we'll put some
offal in it too.
Like I said, nothing
goes to waste.
Having laap be gamey
is a good thing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
difference between what
you consider Thai and Lao?
JAMES SYHABOUT: Thai and Lao--
OK.
Same same, but different.
That's the kind of term they
use a lot, when it comes to--
in, like, in Lao,
like in Thailand.
So a lot of it goes back to
politics, history or politics.
The northeastern part of
Thailand, where I'm from--
which is about a third
of Thailand now--
used to be part of
the Lao Kingdom,
when Thailand was called Siam.
The French came
in, colonized Laos,
which was also part of
Thailand-- like the Isan area,
that's part of Laos.
And then, you know--
I don't know what happened,
but that part of the land
was not fertile.
It was landlocked, it
was dry, it was humid.
You can't do anything
with that land.
It was like-- but it was
like the French traded it,
gave it to Thailand
for I don't know what.
But maybe some kind of
political deal they had.
It's like, hey, we'll give
you this plot of land.
You know?
And borders got redrawn.
And now, part of Isan--
that part of Laos is now part--
it's Thailand.
So when people
ask me-- like, oh,
that's why I'm [INAUDIBLE]
to say where I'm from,
or it's like, oh, I'm Thai-Isan.
Which means I'm nationally
Thai, but I'm culturally Lao.
Does that make more sense?
It's like saying you're Basque.
You know?
It's like, are you Spanish,
or are you French Basque?
So a lot of the food,
as we know, is Thai,
like you see in restaurants,
and Thai restaurants--
and rightfully so, like laap--
a lot of it
originated from Laos.
Because-- from Isan,
which is now Thailand.
So you actually call it Thai.
And during the
Industrial Revolution
in Bangkok, a lot of
the blue collar workers
that are taxi drivers or
construction workers--
they're all Lao.
So they go to the
city, you know,
to roll the dice on
the dream, and make
a living in a big city.
And they brought
their food with them.
This is more delicious
than central Thai food.
It was spicier.
It was different.
So they started
cooking themselves.
And then the public--
the existing public
in central Thailand--
started taking notice.
What is this food?
It's so different from ours.
It's delicious.
It's very, very spicy.
It's funky, it's higher in
salt. And then, you know,
the butlers and the
maids were making
this dish for their bosses.
And they started to like it.
And then that's how the
Lao culture, you know,
infused into Thai culture.
And a lot of dishes, now,
became "Thai," per se--
which is still
correct, you know?
It's just, like, the origin--
tracing back dishes is very,
very interesting to me.
Like, the food
travelled with people.
So I'm just going to
rough chop this breast.
I'm going to do a
mixture of both.
I'm making a small portion, so.
I saved the skin, the fat.
That's, like, the
most prized part.
That's where you
make the cracklings,
to go on top of the laap.
Bones, we save.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Is it
just kind of, like, more rustic?
You know, just kind
of get a cleaver,
and do a coarse cut yourself?
Or would you be able to, like,
ask your butcher to, like,
[INAUDIBLE]--
JAMES SYHABOUT: No.
Just-- like I said, I think,
like, the best part of laap,
the dish itself, is
actually making it.
Yeah.
It's like the most
satisfying part, for me.
It's just this-- it's
very, very rustic.
It's very primitive.
So that's the meat.
Take off the meat, as much
as you can, from the skin.
We're going to render the skin.
The skin, we're going to
slice really, really thin.
And we're going to start
rendering it in it's own fat.
And we'll chop the meat for the
laap, to make some cracklings,
or chicharrones.
That's what they
call it, these days.
Yeah.
It's like, don't worry about
having, like, perfect cuts.
The best part of this
food, and this dish,
is my mom did all this thing
with, like, a two dollar tin
knife that you get
at the grocery store.
I still have one, actually.
And I was-- funny story.
When I was doing
the cookbook shoot,
and we shot the whole-- all the
recipes Hawker Fare Oakland.
We were closed for
lunch at that time.
So we did-- so it's
probably to say
this book has made in Oakland.
Like, from the
recipes, to the photos.
But I went out
and bought, like--
the brand's called Kiwi.
It's like a wooden handle.
They come in different shapes.
I actually bought,
like, a couple of those
knives to do the recipe.
And it just kind of
puts me in the mood.
It's just like-- it's like, OK.
I don't need, like, a
$200 like Masamoto knife
to cook this dish.
It's kind of ridiculous.
Kind of overkill.
It just goes to show that,
you know, like, a simple--
we'll chop this first.
So this, usually, you get
a cleaver or a heavy chef's
knife, and you just go--
you just go at it, actually.
As my mom would do.
But she would, like,
chop the livers into it.
Give it, like, a more
iron-y flavor to it.
Yeah-- I always remember
coming home after school,
and just hearing that noise.
I was like, I know what
we're having for dinner!
[LAUGHS] I know!
And you smell sticky rice
steaming in the background.
It's like, oh-- dad must
have requested laap.
But he doesn't have time
to do it for himself,
so mom has to do it.
If you don't like duck, it can
be done with chicken, as well.
It works just as well.
And I would just
use, like, you know,
thigh meat, The breast meat
becomes too stringy and, like,
mealy.
It doesn't have,
like, nice succulence.
And sometimes we'll
slice offal into it--
like, the gizzards
into it, as well.
And why not?
I got it.
I have it, so.
All right.
We're going to start cooking.
So we've got to render
the skin, first.
So I got--
I got this down.
Got it all figured out, now.
I like to start
from, like, a cold--
cold pan.
Just the duck.
We're going to cook this down,
until it gets, like, crispy.
Should be fairly
quick, actually.
Yeah.
Like, go back to laaps, and
salad-- laap is a salad.
It's always eaten
with sticky rice.
Or with lettuce.
In this case, cabbage.
Kind of depends on what it is.
So we're going to
render the fat.
And of course, beer.
And weirdly enough,
we're asking you--
like, the last
thing we want to do
is, like, what's the best
pairing to eat with laap,
and like, the food in the book?
And I was being honest.
Everyone laughed,
thought it wasn't a joke.
I was like, "Heineken."
So for some reason,
why-- like, even
to this day in the
cookbook there's,
like, some pictures
of a backyard party.
Because, like, Heineken
was always there.
I think it's more--
I think when we came to
America, we viewed it as, like,
an exotic beer.
I don't know if it's
the green bottle--
they don't drink Sing Ha,
they don't drink Beer Lao.
Just so used to that, you know?
Back home.
So it's like Heineken,
which makes sense.
It's, like, really refreshing.
And like, you know,
it's a sessional beer.
You know?
Seemed like [INAUDIBLE].
But yeah-- Heineken's
like the best pairing.
Yeah, I tried other
craft beers with it.
Like, lighter session
beers, lagers.
I was like, eh,
it's not the same.
I think it's just more of,
like, a mindset for me.
And Peter was like,
you drink Heineken?
I'm like, yeah-- situational.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
There you go.
I find your cuisine--
this cuisine-- to be,
probably, the most interesting.
It's one of my
personal favorites.
I haven't been to Laos.
I've had, obviously,
a lot of Thai food.
But, you know, the
interesting complexities
of different ingredients--
umami, textural, color.
Are there other
cuisines that you
would recommend that are similar
to this, other than Thai, Laos,
Burmese, maybe?
JAMES SYHABOUT: Burmese-- yeah.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Yeah.
That have same-- that have
that same kind of complexity,
that just keeps it so exciting?
JAMES SYHABOUT: I love Malaysian
food-- uh, Indonesian food.
You know, they do
more curries, because
of the Muslim population.
But I think it's
just as interesting
to do a lot of permutation to
the spice levels, what not.
Yeah.
Indonesian food.
Burmese, like you
mentioned, as well.
Vietnamese food seems
to be a little bit
on the lighter side of things.
Like, they definitely have
a French influence there.
Like bahn mis-- you know, French
Baguettes, and so on, and so
forth.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: How's
it smell, back there?
We're torturing everyone
behind this wall.
They're like, hey-- that's
not on the menu today!
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES SYHABOUT: So I'm going
to reserve this duck fat,
but I'm going to take
the cracklings off of it.
AUDIENCE: How'd you go from
this kind of food, growing up,
to Commis and [INAUDIBLE]
and [INAUDIBLE]??
JAMES SYHABOUT: Oh--
an interesting story.
I always loved cooking.
So I spent my summers--
we didn't-- you know, parents
couldn't afford to send you
to camp.
So my camp was restaurant camp.
My first job was
at the restaurant.
I was 10 years old, washing
pots and pans, woks,
you know, like, at the mop sink,
because I wasn't tall enough.
I was making five bucks a week.
It was like-- I felt
like I was rich.
[LAUGHS] You know?
It's was like, hey--
I can go into to 7-Eleven
and get all the candy I want!
[LAUGHTER]
But I mean, you know--
I would come home late
at night, turn on the TV.
I started watching
chefs of the world.
I can't remember what
the PBS program is.
And I saw, like, you know--
[INAUDIBLE] in these
white toques, you know?
Copper everywhere, and
their Bonnet stove.
I was like, there's an
elegant side of cooking
that's beyond like, my
mother's cooking, which
is kind of like, makeshift.
Right?
And I loved food.
And my mom was doing all she
can to prevent me to cook.
You know?
It was like, oh, it's
such a hard life.
So much sacrifice.
I was like, yeah,
but I enjoy it.
And I had to convince her.
I'm like, look-- there's
an upside to this.
Like, chefs are highly regarded.
So I went to culinary school.
I knew what I wanted to do
when I was, like, you know--
10 or 11.
I wanted to be a chef, but
in, like, the higher echelon
level of cookery--
haute cuisine.
So you know-- I obsessively
went to magazine racks
in downtown Oakland, looking
through, like, "Gourmet"
and "Bon Appetite,"
at that time.
"Art Culinaire" was a big
one that blew my mind.
And high school, you know,
they had all these, like,
career talks, and
stuff like that.
I got into, like, AP class--
I'm not supposed to tell
this story to my kids, ever.
My wife banned me.
She's like, I don't
know what to do.
You know, I got into a
[INAUDIBLE] program, which
is, like, a college prep class.
I was like, I want to be a chef.
Like, I don't need to
read "Scarlet Letter."
[LAUGHS] I said, I don't need
to remember these big words.
I did it for a year, and
I told my counselor--
I was like, I need
to drop out of AP.
I could do the work.
I just-- I don't see
it benefiting me.
So I dropped all my AP classes.
Took only what I
needed to graduate.
And I started roaming around
Oakland-- the kitchens.
At that time, it
was [INAUDIBLE]..
It was nearby the campus.
So I tried to get in there.
And I was, like, about 15 then.
The owner was like, no way--
I'm not having no minor.
I was like, I'll wash dishes!
I'll do whatever you want.
But then, it wasn't until,
like, culinary school I got,
you know, into-- exposed to,
like, you know-- brown butter,
creme fraiche.
We never used dairy
in our cooking.
It was like, coconut milk
was the closest thing.
And then, like, from
there on, I was just
kind of hungry for more.
And interestingly
enough, my first job
out of culinary school
wasn't at a fine dining
or a European restaurant.
It was actually at a pan-Asian
place, called Betelnut.
Not Betelnut-- it was called
Xanadu's, in Berkeley,
on Fourth Street.
With Alex Ong.
And then, from then
on, I did that.
Started paying back tuition.
And, you know, I still
wanted to pursue this.
And then someone told
me about Manresa.
And the rest is kind
of history, after that.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
You can't skip
over these big restaurants.
What are some of the ways that
Manresa or Fat Duck have kind
of sculpted you to how you are?
And I'm sure there's memorable
episodes in those kitchens.
JAMES SYHABOUT:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, Manresa was
like, you know--
it was like walking into here.
It was like Starship Enterprise.
[LAUGHTER]
It was shiny-- it was
things I saw on TV.
Everyone's in, like, nice,
pristine chef whites.
Everyone's like--
you know, an order
comes in, everyone's
simultaneously saying,
"yes, chef."
Everything is in unison.
I was like, whoa.
I never cooked on a
French top before.
I burned a lot of things
on it, my first go.
And it was the
discipline-- that's
the main thing I went there for.
It's like, the discipline,
of like, you know--
I need to make myself
kind of OCD to do this.
I was kind of OCD anyways.
But like, the precision--
and respect for the craft.
Also, exposure to
different ingredients.
And also, like, the mindframe of
creativity, and how that works.
But also, keeping
in mind, like, you
know-- like, flavor
is paramount.
At the end of the day, our
job is to make food delicious.
But also, like,
the artistry of it.
It's a performance.
It was a big production.
Not just-- even after the
food leaves the kitchen pass,
you know, how is it served,
what utensils are used,
how the servers
explain your dish.
Like, I really got into
and educated myself
on that standpoint
through Manresa.
And then, you know, obviously
Manresa was inspired
by European restaurants.
Because David Kinch--
because he worked in Europe.
And, like, elBulli-- what
the hell is this place?
It's like, are they on Mars?
Are they on Earth?
And I needed to go
see it for myself.
I was getting a filter
of it through him.
And it was my first
time leaving home.
I lived at home for my last--
all my life.
Even after culinary
school, when I was working.
So I was like, yeah--
if I'm going to go away,
I'm going to go away pretty far.
So I went to
[INAUDIBLE],, Fat Duck.
A three month trip
became a year.
And came back, and just kind
of a whole new sense of eating,
and an approach to
cooking, in general.
And just to see how the rest
of the world eats, culturally.
You know, I was, like,
having dinner at 9:00 PM.
That's new to me.
Like in Spain-- you know?
It's just understanding--
like, having a global view
kind of really helping
shape, like, my cuisine.
And also understand, like, food.
You know, it was
like-- it's like
the international language.
Either things taste
good, or they don't.
No matter what it is.
I think you should just
go there and try it.
When I went to the
Basque country,
I landed, I didn't know what
half the things I was eating
were.
Actually, 90%--
like [INAUDIBLE]..
I'm like, well, I'll try it.
That's what I'm here
for, is to learn.
It's trial and error.
It's a classic,
traditional dish.
I mean, if it's a classic
dish, that means it
must taste really, really good.
It stood the test of time.
Yeah.
That's how I kind
of got into it.
But then I eventually
circled back to Hawker Fare
because it's, like--
I want to say Commis is,
like, what I love to do,
but, like, the Hawker
Fare is kind of who I am.
It's kind of bridging the gap.
AUDIENCE: Isn't it
bland, that kind of food,
coming from this kind of food?
JAMES SYHABOUT: It
didn't taste bad.
Because it was more,
like, soothing.
It was more herbaceous.
The flavor delivery
was different.
You know, here, it's
more of the back--
you know, it's spice
and salt. So it's
the side of your tongue.
It's the tip and the back.
Where your [INAUDIBLE]
is more fats.
So everything, like,
coats the pallet more.
Texture, I was used to--
chewing on gristle and
tripe, different things
like that, and everything.
But like, having, like,
a really silk, like,
puree, or something--
you know, that was new to me.
The closest thing we
have is tofu, right?
We didn't have, you know--
blancmange, or panna
cotta, or pom puree.
That's like, OK--
I understand why
this is elegant.
And richness.
I think Asian food has
richness in flavor,
but European food is just rich.
Rich.
Like-- it's, like,
indulgent, right?
Nobody would, like, say Asian
is like-- maybe Japanese food.
But people don't
say it's indulgent.
People always say
it's very flavorful.
Like, real Asian food--
it's rare you say, like,
Asian food's rich.
I think we're going to--
I want to feed you guys.
So I think we'll start
handing out food, actually.
What do you think?
What's up, chef?
[LAUGHTER]
Dude-- you're late, man.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES SYHABOUT: So I'm
going to make this laap.
It's pretty much a one-pot dish.
I keep everything in the pan.
Gonna add some chilis.
I like to use a
mortar and pestle.
You can use a coffee
grinder, but be
careful not to pulse too much,
where it gets obliviated.
I like having, like, bits
of skin, some bits of seeds
in there, as well.
I like to toast the chilis
in, like, a dry pan,
or on the flame, if you have
the luxury to do the [INAUDIBLE]
in a barbecue.
It gives the skin--
the dry chilis
get really croquant,
and really crisp.
It breaks things a bit down.
Put this here.
I'll move this over here.
And then we're going to
start seasoning away.
Everything's all
measured out for me.
I'm cheating.
Toasted rice powder goes in.
Just sticky rice-- the stuff
you eat with your hands--
just dry.
Toasted in a dry pan, to the
color of, like roasted coffee.
Each province in Thailand
have a different color
that they recommend,
but we always--
in Laos, it's always
very, very dark.
We want to get, like,
that toastiness color.
This is ground a
little bit too fine.
It should be-- if you did
it in a mortar and pestle,
it has little bits of rice.
It adds, like, a
smokiness to the dish.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES SYHABOUT: Almost used as,
like, a binding agent, as well.
And it's almost
like an emulsifier.
But it's also for,
like, texture, as well.
Fish sauce-- this
is, like, the--
I want to say extra
virgin of fish sauce.
It's fish sauce, and
then you have [INAUDIBLE]
or [INAUDIBLE]---- which
is also a fish sauce.
So we have two-- we're
doing a fish sauce process.
All the sediment
falls to the bottom,
the clear stuff
floats to the top.
You decant it.
You get the clear
stuff more refined--
like, say, in first press.
And then you have, like, the
deliciousness of [INAUDIBLE],,
which is--
a lot of city, like, Thai
people really don't like it.
It's really, really strong.
But that separates us
from the North and South.
There's also-- you know, it's
high salt, so it acts as, like,
a preservative.
So we got that all in.
I'm going to slice
some lemongrass.
Lemongrass, I like to
slice from the root end.
And you kind of slice
this slightly on a bias.
It actually makes
it more tender.
It's easier-- it makes it easier
to slice, because the fibers,
you're cutting
against the grain.
Paper thin.
So, on this recipe,
there isn't any citrus
at all, or lime juice.
The citrus comes
from the lemongrass,
not as much for flavor, but
more so for the aromatics.
And you have to
slice this fairly
paper thin to make
it digestible,
or it can become, like,
pretty unpleasant to eat.
OK.
That's plenty.
Throw that in there.
Shallots-- sliced to the
side, rather than half-moons.
And laap is technically
served room temp--
it never should be warm.
You can serve it
warm, but, you know,
if it's left out to room temp,
that's perfectly OK, too.
OK.
Put the shallots in there.
We're going to add fresh
Thai chilis to this batch.
I like it--
I like when Thai
chilis are in there,
because they're like little
minefields, you know,
as you chew.
Catch somebody off guard.
It becomes lots of fun.
That's when the
Heineken comes out.
[LAUGHTER]
We can do scallions.
With scallions, I like to
use the white and the green,
so we have a mixture of both.
The scallions, too-- like, I
learned I was making a mistake,
making these recipes.
I was cutting things too fine.
Like, I'm still used to--
the only thing about
fine dining is,
I became a jarhead
of refinement.
Which kind of works against me,
when I was making these dishes.
I was overthinking it.
Things were too fine,
and it gets lost.
You know, things were cut
certain ways with intention,
so it would be very distinct.
All right.
That goes in.
And then we have cilantro.
Cilantro, mint.
Cilantro, like, you
use all of it-- the
stems, and stuff like that.
That's the one thing,
every time my mom comes
to Commis the first
thing she walks up to is
to look at the compost bin.
[LAUGHTER]
And she always is like--
did somebody misplace this?
I'm like, no, mom-- we
only want the flowers.
It's like, we already
have cilantro.
Like, the guys would be eating
cilantro salad for the last,
like, two weeks.
And she just shakes her head.
And she goes, how
do you guys make--
how do you make any money here?
And I'm like, we don't.
It's an art project.
[LAUGHS]
Add that.
Add a little mint.
Torn.
And like I said, it's
kind of a rustic dish,
so you don't have to chop
your mint or cilantro fine.
Use everything you can.
Kind of piece it together.
AUDIENCE: Is it true that
Commis doesn't make any money?
JAMES SYHABOUT: Most--
restaurants are hard.
They're difficult.
Margins are so slim.
Like Commis--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES SYHABOUT: Huh?
AUDIENCE: I would have thought
that with all the recognition,
it would--
JAMES SYHABOUT: I
mean, it's sustainable.
I'm not going to be driving
a Tesla anytime soon.
[LAUGHS] Yeah-- then just mix
it like you would a salad.
The more herbs, the better.
It's supposed to be
spicy and aromatic.
Add this guy.
I should taste this, huh?
And it's always eaten with,
like, a wedge of cabbage.
The cabbage, it's kind of like
you break off petals of it,
and you either eat
the laap first,
with a ball of sticky rice--
how many people had
sticky rice before?
No?
Cool.
You know how to eat sticky
rice with your hands, right?
I always tell people,
pretend it's a tortilla.
That's the easiest
way to explain it.
Like, the sticky
rice is your utensil.
Little slices of cucumber,
some garnish on the side.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: It's
a pretty veg-forward dish,
if you consider it.
There's a lot going on, there.
JAMES SYHABOUT: Yeah.
I actually made this
with tofu, before.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
It's delicious.
JAMES SYHABOUT: For a guest.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
What do you guys think?
JAMES SYHABOUT: And then
Thai chilis for the--
Thai chilis for the brave,
and that's all of it.
Yeah.
Thank you.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Nice job.
Nice job.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMES SYHABOUT: Sorry.
I didn't mean to make a mess.
[LAUGHS] Cool.
How's the food tasting?
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
It's delicious.
JAMES SYHABOUT: Thank you to the
team, back there, that produced
the food you guys are eating.
Yeah.
They did a very good job.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
Thank you, team.
[APPLAUSE]
So a huge thanks to
not only everyone
in the back, who
prepared the team,
but also to Laura and the
team that set this up.
Getting these food talks
going looks easy, here,
but it's a massive amount
of work to pull chefs out
of their restaurants, to
get these kitchens reserved,
and to have all of you show
up so eagerly, as you did.
So thank you for
coming, and thank you
to the team that planned it.
Enjoy your snacks, and then
Chef will be signing books
right after that.
And I know most of you have
a day job to go back to,
so we'll try to keep
it short and sweet.
So again, huge round of
applause for Chef James.
JAMES SYHABOUT:
Thank you very much.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Nice job.
[APPLAUSE]